[Música]
Bienvenidos a France 24 y a radio
Francia internacional estamos en la sede
de Naciones Unidas en Nueva York y
nuestro invitado de hoy es el secretario
general Antonio Gutiérrez es un gran
placer estar con ustedes y para esta
entrevista me acompaña Cristóbal de rfi
señor secretario general Buenas tardes
señor secretario estamos en vísperas de
la asamblea general y evidentemente
Ucrania será un tema principal
Quiero hacerle una pregunta sobre lo que
se descubrió en la ciudad de isyung
una región que fue reconquistada por las
fuerzas ucranianas las autoridades
ucranianas afirman a haber descubiertos
centenas de cuerpos entre los cuales
algunos tienen indicios de ejecución y
tortura
el presidente ucraniano
bolodimirselenski dice que los rusos son
torturadores los líderes de la Unión
Europea afirman que los rusos incluidos
sus dirigentes deben rendir cuentas ante
la justicia
reacción
en primer lugar durante la Guerra en
Ucrania
hemos asistido a constantes violaciones
de los Derechos Humanos
internacional
y del derecho internacional humanitario
nos enteramos de esta noticia en la
oficina del alto comisionado de las
Naciones Unidas para los refugiados
irá al terreno para analizar la
información y espero que la cpu
la Corte Penal Internacional
la Corte Penal Internacional que está
ahí Y que en mi opinión es el
instrumento más importante para la
rendición de cuentas
voy a tener la capacidad de hacer una
investigación seria y después
naturalmente crear las condiciones para
que los responsables de las atrocidades
respondan
en el frente señor secretario general
los combates continúan o los que trata
de hacer avanzar su ventaja militar
Vladimir Putin ha contestado con un tono
amenazante
abro comillas ya veremos Cómo terminará
la contraofensiva de los ucranianos
nosotros no tenemos prisa
las posibilidades de un acuerdo de paz
están ahora más lejos que nunca teme que
haya una escalada militar que vaya hasta
el uso eventual de un arma nuclear
tengo una escalada militar
la posibilidad creo que la posibilidad
del uso de bombas nucleares es algo
inaceptable
inaceptable tan horrible que espero que
esa hipótesis nunca se consideren
pero Es evidente que como usted lo dijo
las perspectivas de una negociación de
paso es muy lejanas
creo que tanto los ucranianos como los
rusos piensan que pueden ganar la guerra
y no veo ninguna posibilidad para
establecer a corto plazo
una negociación seria de paz
Quisiera regresar a la cuestión nuclear
Ya lo hablamos pero de manera más
concreta me refiero a la central nuclear
de esa por ella es la más grande de
Europa sabemos que la agencia
internacional de energía atómica llevó
una misión al terreno este sábado
supimos que Aparentemente sería
reconectada a la red eléctrica o que lo
estaba pero a pesar de todo La amenaza
permanece usted pidió una zona
desmilitarizada alrededor de la central
pero por ahora estamos lejos de eso
verdad no no Hemos llegado a eso
la propuesta que le hice el Consejo de
Seguridad fue primero que se necesitaba
un acuerdo para no bombardear la central
[Música]
desde la central
Es evidente Y en segundo lugar
dije que se debía definir un perímetro
para que las tropas rusas pudieran
retirarse con el compromiso
de que los ucranianos no tratarían de
tomar militarmente la central
es decir convertir la central en un
instrumento estrictamente civil y creo
que eso es lo que necesitamos para que
la central pueda ser reactivada todos
los reactores están cerrados el pasado
22 de Julio en Estambul gracias a su
mediación y a la del presidente Turco se
llegó a un acuerdo entre los rusos y los
ucranianos para que pudieran salir tanto
el trigo ucraniano como el trigo y los
fertilizantes rusos pero el miércoles
pasado
creo que Vladimir Putin le dijo por
teléfono que ese acuerdo no estaba
funcionando por dos razones
primero porque el trigo ucraniano iría
más a Europa que a África
y luego porque el Triángulo es
fertilizante rusos no iban a poder salir
de Rusia a causa de los bloqueos de los
occidentales es cierto lo que dice
Vladimir Putin
parcialmente cierto pero estamos
resolviendo esos problemas
en primer lugar no hay un acuerdo hay
dos acuerdos
un acuerdo sobre las exportaciones
ucranianas
que es un acuerdo entre rusos ucranianos
Naciones Unidas y Turquía
de acuerdo entre Naciones Unidas y Rusia
Naciones Unidas haga su mejor esfuerzo
frente a Estados Unidos
que han establecido sanciones para que
como siempre decimos de manera
públican a los fertilizantes y a los
productos alimenticios
que eso puede hacer llevado a la
práctica la verdad es que hay
dificultades por cuestiones indirectas
cuestiones de pagos cuestiones de
aseguramiento
cuestiones de acceso a puertos porque
muchas de esas exportaciones se hacen
mediante la Unión Europea
Tuvimos una negociación muy importante y
muy seria con la Unión Europea y Estados
Unidos y creo que vamos en camino a
encontrar una solución para los
problemas que todavía quedan sin
solución
realmente necesitamos los fertilizantes
el mercado de los fertilizantes está en
una situación terrible en África se ve
por todas partes que se está cultivando
menos que el año pasado hay que
restablecer la normalidad del mercado de
fertilizantes
al mismo tiempo hay que decir que hubo
exportaciones de productos alimenticios
ucranianos hacia todo el mundo
hacia países europeos hacia otros países
ricos pero también hacia países de
ingresos medios como China India o
Egipto y hacia países más pobres y el
programa mundial de alimentos ya hizo
salir tres barcos hacia el cuerno de
África quiero volver rápidamente al
acuerdo nuclear sobre Irán hubo
negociaciones que parecían alentadoras
pero desde entonces la esperanza está
desapareciendo aquí en Nueva York que
estarán sin duda los actores principales
de esa negociación está preocupado y
Espera que tal vez aquí se puede hacer
el progreso que no se ha podido hacer
Estoy en contacto permanente con Irán y
con los países que negocian
le pedí que negociación
[Música]
Naciones Unidas no tiene una
intervención directa
[Música]
siendo totalmente Franco hace dos
semanas estaba convencido de que
llegaríamos a un acuerdo después las
cosas se complicaron todavía tengo
esperanza pero creo que hay dificultades
enormes
realmente se necesita un esfuerzo
suplementario para superarlas
pienso que no sé cómo decirlo en francés
el jcpoa el acuerdo sobre lo nuclear
digamoslo así
el acuerdo sobre los nuclear ha sido una
de las grandes victorias diplomáticas de
los últimos años
una lástima que Estados Unidos lo
abandonará
recomenzar sus actividades en ese ámbito
y es vital restablecerlo
En mi opinión es una cuestión vital
Espero que esta semana pueda ayudarnos a
avanzar en la dirección correcta
tras las inundaciones letales en
Pakistán usted estuvo en el terreno eso
fue hace unos días
denunció los efectos desastrosos de las
concentraciones de gases de efecto
invernadero en Glasgow en la cop26 el
año pasado los países desarrollados se
comprometieron a entregar cada año 40
mil millones de dólares a los países más
pobres para que se adapten se han
mantenido las promesas comidas
a la 26
bueno en primer lugar hay que decir que
el problema central de la lucha contra
el cambio climático está en este punto
en una situación que yo considero el
desastrosa
necesitamos comenzar inmediatamente
reducir las emisiones
la visto la devastación gigantesca en
Pakistán
pero también hemos visto la sequía en
África gato
cuatro años de sequía en el cuerno de
África cuando tendríamos que estar
reduciendo las emisiones
las emisiones siguen subiendo
señor secretario general comisionado de
la ONU para los Derechos Humanos publicó
un informe muy esperado sobre los
crímenes cometidos por china en su
región
el informe habla sobre la detención
masiva de poblaciones y sobre posibles
crímenes contra la humanidad sucede a
China que aplicar a las recomendaciones
de su informe chi evidentemente se negó
se queda en eso al hablar de crímenes
contra la humanidad no habría que pedir
más decir más
naturalmente como usted lo sabe y están
los instrumentos que se dedican a esas
cuestiones
en este momento nuestra posición Clara
es que hay que restablecer unas
condiciones en las que la comunidad
puede ver que sus derechos humanos son
respetados y más que eso
que esa comunidad pueda sentir que su
identidad cultural religiosa es
respetada
y que al mismo tiempo tiene las
condiciones para ser parte de la
sociedad en general
y que su voz Es acogida en la sociedad
en general
Espero que esta cuestión que es una
cuestión esencial
puede resolverse de manera efectiva y
naturalmente están las organizaciones
internacionales que competencias en esa
materia
en Haití el aumento del precio del
combustible está provocando desde hace
unos días
disturbios y saqueos usted acaba de
hacer un llamado a todas las partes para
aplacar la crisis
hay que volver a subvencionar El
combustible para las poblaciones más
necesitadas y el plan de urgencia de
algunos millones de dólares del que
acaba de obtener el desbloqueo
está a la altura de los retos
desde el punto de vista de los
principios creo que hay que subvencionar
a las familias y no los combustibles
y no es exactamente lo mismo
porque permite que las familias obtengan
los recursos que necesitan
y no se traduce en un beneficio para los
combustibles fósiles
pero en el caso de Haití hemos visto
varias reuniones del Consejo de
Seguridad
yo estoy convencido de que hay que
reintroducir una seguridad
seriamente
y la propuesta que hice
porque se necesita un programa
internacional de apoyo a la formación y
al equipamiento de la policía
pero que bajo esa perspectiva habrá que
tener una fuerza robusta capaz de
ponerle fin a las acciones de las bandas
no con eso Entonces todos las conocemos
en Portugal en Francia y fuerzas de la
policía robustas
y creo que hay que tener una en Haití
durante esta transición de formación y
de equipamiento de una policía que por
ahora es ineficaz
tiene que haber una fuerza que realmente
pueda poner orden frente a una ciudad y
también frente a un país completamente
controlado por bandas no son movimientos
políticos desafortunadamente son bandas
que también están infiltradas por
personas vinculadas al poder económico y
al poder político
señor secretario general no nos queda
mucho tiempo pero quisiera que hablemos
sobre África sobre Mali en este momento
hay una crisis diplomática con Costa de
Marfil Mali tiene detenidos a 46
soldados madrileños a los que llaman
mercenarios Costa de Marfil dice que no
lo son que estaban trabajando al
servicio de la misión de la ONU la
minusma primero rápidamente considera
que son mercenarios no no son
mercenarios Es evidente y le hago un
llamado a las autoridades malienses para
que ese problema se las llamó habló con
el presidente brasileño hemos estado en
contacto permanente con ellos con el
señor goita no hable directamente con
goita
pero estamos en contacto permanente la
delegación
recibiré a la delegación de Mali y es
algo que para mí es muy importante
hay que resolver ese problema Y en
segundo lugar hay que reconocer que la
situación en el sagel actualmente es muy
muy difícil
las poblaciones se manifiestan contra
Los cascos azules de la molusco
porque acusan a esos cascos azules de no
protegerlos contra los Rebeldes hubo
manifestaciones letales en el mes de
julio
considerará una salida anticipada de
esos cascos azules antes del 2024 e
incluso antes de la presidencial a
finales de 2023 como se lo piden las
autoridades
hay un programa de reducción de la
fuerza que se acordó con el gobierno
pero hablemos con franqueza
de población
las poblaciones quieren y contemplan que
las fuerzas de la ONU sean capaces de
combatir los movimientos que los atacan
chile y de garantizarles la protección
prestamos ante una situación
extremadamente difícil
miremos el m23 el m23 ha sido como lo
saben la razón de estas últimas
manifestaciones el hecho de que Naciones
Unidas no sea capaz de combatir al m23
la verdad es que actualmente el m23 es
un ejército moderno con equipamientos
pesados mejores que los equipamientos de
la molusco
Esos equipamientos vienen de Ruanda
vienen de alguna parte parece estar
diciendo que sí vienen de alguna parte
de alguna parte que está al lado no
nacieron en la selva vienen de alguna
parte
lo que se necesita En mi opinión y es lo
esencial
es una discusión seria entre Congo
Ruanda y uganda
tener una perspectiva conjunta
para evitar esta situación permanente
que siempre nos hace retroceder cuando
hay un avance
es necesario que esos países lleguen a
un acuerdo de manera mutua
y es necesario que esos países cooperen
efectivamente por la seguridad del este
del Congo y también por las garantías de
seguridad no hay que olvidarlo de Ruanda
y uganda no hay que olvidar que la fda
es un movimiento que se originó en
uganda no hay que olvidar que en el
Congo Todavía están las fdlr que es un
movimiento que salió de los cutus
responsables por el genocinio todos los
países tienen preocupaciones deben
llegar a un acuerdo porque hay que
pensar que una fuerza de mantenimiento
de la paz puede resolver los problemas
ahora que hay fuerzas militares
extremadamente bien armadas es imposible
y las poblaciones naturalmente no lo
entienden y para nosotros es un problema
general en cuanto al futuro de las
operaciones para el mantenimiento de la
paz señor secretario general Gracias por
habernos concedido esta entrevista
Gracias a ustedes por habernos
acompañado en France 24 y radio Francia
internacional
[Música]